hey folks time for another movie
retrospective yeah it's a good one we
grew up with oh yeah on HBO itself the
funhouse 1981 I think yeah all-star cast
directed by the dude who did Texas
Chainsaw man it'll be Hooper yeah a very
different kind of movie but just as good
quality some similarities actually like
I don't you know the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre is like a classic I feel like
this one is kind of like an underrated
Jim kind of thing sorry my voice still
sounds crappy well if you listen to our
Richard Ramirez show I was talking about
how he had a little bit of a cold well
it went into like a big huge whopping
cold that's kind of kicking my ass
yeah and I'm actually just now got my
voice back I didn't even talk yesterday
so sorry I kind of sound like crap
this is a good one because it's like
it's it's very much like the first one a
certain way where it's like as a family
yeah but family involved in crime but
then there's a darker so freaks and
where those freaks and weirdos involved
and they're they're working inside a
carnival and then some kids get wrapped
up with them you know and there's a true
monster in this movie yeah it's kind of
like a combo between their like kind of
a low-key slasher and like a monster
movie yeah cuz I mean even though he's
kind of a person I mean he's kind of a
monster too but this actually I want to
give a shout out to friend of the show
Rob who was the one who sent us the Dino
gave this so thank you very much it
actually you know what's amazing is that
I had seen this movie several times in
the 80s like on VHS and I think I saw a
cable a few times and it always looked
real muddy and shitty and like the
lighting is bad and stuff but now that
it's been restored the DVD and the blue
and I've heard the blu-ray is really
good too yeah this actually looks
amazing this is like a really nice
looking movie yeah we got a standard DVD
there wasn't any extras or anything on
it yeah just a trailer and it looked
pretty tight it looked a lot better than
it did on television oh yeah I didn't
get to see this in the theater
no I the the monster always called him
tad but tab is actually the little
brother
that was in the jar yeah that was the
fetus and I don't know what his name is
Gunther Gunther his name although I
don't know if they ever called him no
then they just called him boy
movie yeah his dad just called him boy
yeah boy you know and yeah the boy mask
looked a lot better on DVD than it
looked back on television HBO
oh yeah he's super pale and he's
basically two-headed in a way it's kind
of his head's kind of trying to split
apart into two different heads and he's
got he's albino
fangs pig eyes he has to wear a
Frankenstein mask in order to move
around in public that's how ugly is do
you know that like this didn't even
occur to me but I was watching an
interview with tobe Hooper early today
earlier today where he was talking about
this movie and he said I didn't really
make this explicit in in the movie but
you know the scene where the four
teenagers like oh and they're in like
the freaks of nature exhibit and there's
like a cow was a female into this and
there's a cow with a cleft palate yeah
he's like I almost wanted to imply that
Gunther the monster is like that one of
the cows was his mom oh yeah yeah I see
it like you know you know it means that
that's why he might have been Park ow
yeah because he's like after after I saw
like the two-headed cow a cow with a
cleft palate they were gonna you know
put in the movie yeah it's like oh we
should make the monster look like that
just to kind of hint like they didn't
really say anything about anybody you
know cuz he had a human dad obviously
because the one guy a carnival barker
dad dad was in the jar with the damn
cows Amber's in the back in the Freak
Show so maybe he was also oh yeah calf
cow I didn't make the connect I didn't
either but look I thought they were
trying to say that maybe they came from
a place where the water was bad or
something were michi yeah that's how I
took it but that's what tobe Hooper said
he said he's like I didn't want to like
make it explicit or anything but I just
thought it would be amusing if we made
the monster like look kind of like that
so you'd like implicitly make that
connection yeah maybe the cow was this
mom like maybe there's some cow [ __ ]
going on at this carnival I've got a
cool cast it's got a 70s hot rod in
there look I think that might have been
Shiva or camara I didn't really get hey
guys the Pontiac LeMans is that what it
was
okay so I was sure I was saying what
kind of car is that I kept waiting I
think it's a Pontiac alone please
correct me if I'm wrong but I can't I'm
not a car person can't wait to see that
the badges on it I never got to see it
look it looked like a Camaro or some
Romanian Chevelle but it was the cool
cuties in it had a girl who played Stasi
and Walton and in Amadeus if you ever
saw that movie this was her first maybe
actually I really liked her in the
Elizabeth barrage and her perky boobies
she could see them yeah in the first
right off of that yeah as soon as the
movie starts pretty much you just how
you can see her naked
fanservice tooth for the boys yeah yeah
it's like I had actually seen Amadeus
which came out in 1984 which is actually
one of my favorite movies of all time I
love [ __ ] Amadeus and um so she's she
played Mozart's wife Costanza and
Amadeus so I saw that before that and
what I saw this I was like hey it's done
baby yeah that's like one of the only
other things I never see during yeah and
she's cute as hell in this though yeah
Gunther his dad was pretty cool in it he
was out in the front you know and he was
one thing that really kind of stuck with
me as a kid is just how creepy he was as
a barker trying a front house and you
know didn't he'd be music there is no
escape yeah there is no release from the
faun house I feel like just creepy I
feel like that was like sampled in some
music or something like that and please
like I said if anybody is like more of a
person like super into goth that I am I
could swear that there was a song by
corpus delicti who were a French Gotham
and in the 90s and I swear that in one
of their songs and I can't remember
which one it is that there was a sample
from a movie and it sounded awfully lot
like the Barker from this video which it
very well could have been who is man
enough enter this world of darkness
I like the funhouse yeah and also fun
fact and this again this is another
thing that happened in Florida yeah this
is another thing that I didn't notice
yeah so the guy that played the carnival
barker that was
Hunter's dad the monsters dad that was
an actor named Kevin Conway now
apparently he was a Broadway actor and
he had just won a Tony at least
according to tobe Hooper and the
interview that I saw he's like yeah he
just won a Tony like before I asked him
to be in this movie sex so when I asked
him to be in this movie and he's like I
want you to be a carnival barker and
he's like well what are these other
parts so that because there's three
Barker's in this movie all three of them
are played by that same guy which I
didn't even realize and Rosie they they
don't they don't seem to be the same guy
no and that's what you're saying he's
like that was a he's he's like okay
that's interesting so you want one of
these three parts and he's like yeah I
want to play these three parts oh he's
like oh I want to see what this dude's
gonna do with this I wonder why I wanted
to play all three of and just he said he
didn't know he's just like because and
he's like oh that's interesting
okay well you know knock yourself out so
Kevin Conway was the name of the actor
and tobe Hooper was like I was amazed
because it's like a lot of people don't
realize that all three dudes you know he
was doing the peep show guy yeah you
know cuz he had different wigs and yet
on a different voice and stuff like that
like I had no idea that that was all
three of those were the same guy but
they are that's just that kills me yeah
but yeah so it's a good movie starts off
with little boy hunting down his sister
little homage to psycho a little bit of
Halloween and also a little bit almost
kind of like you had a bedroom kind of
like the kid from Salem's Lot with all
the damn monster also a cooper movie
yeah yeah and he comes after his sister
with a knife in the shower there was
just a rubber knife he's just tried to
scare and she had to go on a date with
this with this guy and buns on a double
date with buzz-buzz kind of the second
jock tough guy with his muscle car and
is it better hey yeah he's a dick he's
kind of a douche yet yeah and he she
lies to her dad and she about going to
this carnival but yes [ __ ] went went
down the year before when his car yeah
they don't go into it a lot but they're
like Hayden those girls disappear or get
murdered or something like that and yeah
that carnival was somewhere else
it really wasn't supposed to be going
then but the little brother overheard
her on the phone lying
setting the whole thing up that she was
actually gonna go little brothers of the
yeah although I have two little brothers
in there yeah so she goes there with her
boyfriend on the double date and the
little brother goes over there I think
he went around foot didn't eat or was on
a bike he did yeah cuz remember he was
walking and then on his way to the
carnival like he runs into all these
weirdos like this one guy like pulls
over and tries to pick him up like a
pedophile or something like points a gun
out of Majid burn everything yeah okay
that's weird
so both the brother and sister are in
there but you know I don't think they
ever meet do they they do not they don't
ever meet so they have two separate
adventures both involving gun third the
monster yeah you know I used to call him
Ted yeah when I was a boy Ted's was the
brother that didn't matter
yeah I guess then it was the twin that
didn't make yeah would they maybe they
were conjoined twins I think that was
the implication there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on yeah it's kind of movie now
that like you think about it yeah like I
said on the surface it seems very much
like an early 80's
kind of a you know kind of a
bog-standard slasher like mixed with a
monster movie but then like when you
kind of watch it there's like a lot of
other little things going yeah it was it
was you know seen as a kid you know it
scared me scare me was a creepy flick
well there's something inherently creepy
about carnival
yeah you know with all the and tobe
Hooper was saying that - he's like
that's what intrigued him about the
project I mean he had only done I guess
he'd only directed to movies part of
this he did Texas Chainsaw Massacre in
1974 and then he did eaten alive in 1977
and this was the next one that he did
the next one that he did after this was
poltergeist which like I said they don't
know if he directed it or Steven
Spielberg or whatever but he gets the
credit on it anyway yeah but yeah so
this was the one in between eaten alive
and poltergeist and he said that he had
always been creeped out and fascinated
by carnivals just because he's like I
was always intrigued with the idea of
like this whole like tribe of people
that just like went from place to place
they were like these itinerant people
that just like would come to your town
and like set up all this stuff and they
always seemed like really seedy
like kind of creepy and [ __ ] but also
kind of fascinating so he's like so
you'd really want to do something with
that he didn't write the screenplay but
um you know I think someone had sent him
the screenplay
hoping that he would direct it like
because he was trying to write it in a
way that like tobe Hooper would do that
so yeah the movie starts off with a bang
- I mean they're walking around and
having a good time and in the carnival
they're looking at them peep shows and
freak shows and then they make this pact
that they're gonna spend the night and
they're gonna spend the night in the
damp in the funhouse like their friend
did cries I think one so the girls get
on a payphone and they cross wire it so
each one so the parents think their zone
says house so they break into the front
house and wait for dinner up and up top
up above it in which it doesn't mean it
doesn't make any sense um really because
there's supposed to be a traveling
carnival but it's obviously that they're
in a it's obvious to me that the the
funhouse is a permanent construction and
it has a basement in it no because at
tobe Hooper was saying it was like we
couldn't afford to build our own
carnival clearly because this this movie
costs like maybe two million dollars
isn't that and he said what we decided
to do was shoot it in Miami because
that's where all of the traveling
carnivals go in the winter um you know
he's like in the neighborhood where we
were staying was like super sketchy
people not that it stops back every year
so it ma ya had a place they set it up
yeah they sent the fun house up in a
place that was built for a fun house
yeah cuz it had never had conveyor belts
and had gears and drives I mean it was a
building anyway they're up and they're
up in the attic and they're watching you
know they're spying on the carnies and
yet some [ __ ] goes down one of the
attendants who's wearing this
Frankenstein costume has got a limp he's
obviously handicapped he's trying to you
can't he can barely talk you can't
understand what he's saying
he's trying to cut a prostitution deal
with the damn fortune-teller Madame Zena
and Adam Xena who's like 80 yeah he's
probably not not sure at all she's in
her 40s probably I remember being an old
hag but I saw her again I was like
she pretty high yeah you know you like
granny porn you know I mean she's not
that bad you know like an old bad but
I'm like you know mmm
ya know so yeah and there was a good
scene with them when they were in their
spoofing on her earlier getting a gettin
fortune tally and there's a weird part
where this is before you know went
before they snuck into the place there's
a part where they were there were
riffing on Matt of Xena's fortune
telling and she got up and kicked him
out when she kicked him out she dropped
the crystal ball the crystal ball rolled
away but then it rolled back to her and
she grabbed it so she's like so there
was a there was an implication that
there was more to Madame Zena than met
the eye but she was also turning tricks
you know she's I guess well [ __ ] or
she's gypsy from New York cause she had
a strong New York accent what you got
man he was getting $100 from that yeah
she talked from that deformed kid yeah
she talked him into hundred dollars to
break it off and they were there
watching and he got so excited that he
had what they call in the business of
premature ejaculator but she was giving
him a [ __ ] she's trying to get him
ready but he was already ready probably
just like that was easy so she wouldn't
get it wouldn't come the money he
wouldn't give him the money back and he
started fighting every funds yeah and
and he accidentally killed her and her
in a fit of rage he threw her into a
power box yeah when they were fighting
over the money so he goes back to tell
his dad maybe they were up there and
they witnessed at the saw it she goes
back and gets his dad in his Desmond
you're gonna give on it out for her I
could have got you know all kind of
stuff yeah you know I'll kind of - you
don't want about money where is the
money
yeah cuz all the money is in the - in a
cash box in Scott and it was all gone
because one of the one of the s one of
the teenager yeah he stole the vessel
and he starts turning on Ted what'd you
do at the money what'd you do with the
money I called him dead himself right
beat yourself hit yourself beat just
says he's got trying to beat himself it
was a cool scene it's like I don't even
have to do it yeah for me well all that
was gone
they heard him upstairs and he was he
dropped his lighter through this yeah
the light fell I was like oh hello
because I he tries to talk him down and
everything and thus the chase begins
yeah because not only did they witness
that murder dad had mentioned earlier
before that he would bury her kind of
like them two girls that he had killed
the year he said Oh we'll just blame it
on the local yeah so he he the dad now
knew that there were locals up above and
not only do they know about Madame Zena
they knew about the other girls yeah
that Gunter had killed that the year
before and he also said some stuff he
implied that there were some other ones
too well yes there's normal never just
that many right so they're always gonna
like so the games begin at this point
you know they're trying to hunt down
these poor teenagers through the
funhouse in the middle of the night to
kill and I don't want to spoil
everything because the movies so old
they were not a lot people haven't seen
it it is it is a good movie and it had
it had a pretty strong ending for it was
for them for a movie of its time yeah
best day of its budget I mean like I
said yeah it was very low-budget it
actually made most of its budget back I
think it made about eight million in the
theatre excuse me but um I would call it
a slasher movie but it's not super gory
um you know there's a couple scenes that
are like kind of you know there's an axe
in someone's head or something like that
it's not it's more atmospheric I feel
like there was some action in it though
- yeah more like a thriller yeah the
monster thriller I mean I kind of liked
that because I I feel like a some of the
reviews I've read and I and I was
reading some reviews of people that had
seen it as a kid and thought it was
boring but then they saw it again as an
adult and they're like no it's like they
actually appreciated that it took time
to like set up all the characters and
the interaction between the characters
like before this long chase sequence
like through the funhouse with the
monster guy like going out there then
definitely the highlight
the movie is the characters in the
dialogue I mean they're definitely
spinning a tale to you and I mean
they're telling you a story and they do
kind of keep you interested in the story
than the characters yeah you know it's
it's not one that it's not one that is
where the characters don't matter
there's a lot of stories that you don't
really give a city's put it on whatever
I remember kind of got that way when
were kids cuz we saw so many times yeah
we were just this is on cable play it
over and over again when it was new so
it got burned that you get burned out on
it when you were a kid but you still
liked it you know
yeah but revisit it again I you know
it's I forgot what a good movie it was
and like I said now that we've seen it
like in its restored state yeah it
almost looked like well tobe Hooper
filmed it in like what what are they
called like anamorphic widescreen which
he really likes working in and like I
said when you saw it on cable orange
shitty VHS she couldn't really tell yeah
but when you see it now that it's been
restored it really looks fantastic
it almost it at times like especially
the scenes inside the funhouse it almost
looks like a jolly movie because yes
like I'd be like yeah they'll be like a
close-up of like some weird like
animatronic monster up here and they're
like it's green and then like in the
background it's all red and then it's
like dark all in between and it looks
like super cool like he really has an
eye for you know just kind of the
framing and the colors yeah and like
making it look like kind of lurid and
[ __ ] it looked as cool to say like kind
of like Evil Dead 2 I mean not yeah this
is the same things of course did happen
and it's Evil Dead 2 was really strong
on special effects but it looked to be
like around the same quality yeah yeah
or the color and giallo
look it did it looked Italian it's it
and like I said a lot of American
directors were really influenced
specially John Carpenter and I presume
to be Hooper's well we're really
influenced by that genre yeah I mean
that's kind of where the whole slasher
thing came from now you see it does look
kind of like a carpenter flick when
carpenters being good so yeah that's
what I like I said but it reminded me
very much and some people have said it
looks kind of a little bit Hitchcockian
in places as well and the way they kind
of build up the suspense
honestly one of the best scenes in it is
when you know the
little kid who is Elizabeth barrages
little brother when the parents come to
pick him up and she sees them like
through the exhaust fan of the funhouse
but she can't get out and she's like
screaming for her dad she can see him
he's right there yeah and she's like
screaming and screaming and they show it
from the outside and she's like daddy
daddy and like you can't hear anything
and it's like that scene kind of got me
because I'm just like oh man he sucks
she's gonna get [ __ ] murder you know
if this movie kind of compares to I
think that probably like the fog but
yeah yeah just the story's tighter more
happens in it it's in it but it looks
kind of like the fog it looks but looks
like it was on the same budget yeah you
know and if you'd have told me now that
I think this is a comparable budget I
think I think Toby Cooper said it costs
about two million to make yeah and like
I said they shot it in Miami that's a
real carnival a lot of the extras or
actual carnies um the guy that played
Gunther the monster was actually a mime
he said we didn't have that idea until
he's like we he's like me and a bunch of
the crew were like out at some club or
some restaurant or something in Miami
one night and we were talking about
casting the UM the monster apart and
he's like we saw this mime artist like
in the street or something and he's like
that's what we should do we should get
him I'm like to play that part because
the big as it's like this kind of
physical type of thing so they got the
guy to play him was like it was a mime
so I thought that was actually a really
good idea also the reason that he wears
a Frankenstein mask is because he was
just gonna wear a generic mask over his
regular face I think Rick Baker did the
effects for this actually that's why
they look so good but um since the movie
was produced by Universal and obviously
they had they had the rights to all the
universal monsters so they decided yeah
all right yeah so they decided to use
that fact the kid had nothing but
Universal Monsters in his room that's
why in that why because they had the
rights to use all that so they figured
might as well they wanted to kind of
homage that as well now one thing that I
kind of wanted to make mention of that I
thought was really funny and our British
listeners will probably appreciate this
is that during the video nasty fear
in the 1980s this movie was actually
kind of singled out as a video in a
steam they attempted to prosecute it as
a video nasty but were unsuccessful
because clearly there's not a lot of
blood in there there's no gore there's
nothing that I mean considering some of
the other movies that are on those I'm
not saying they should have censored any
just one of them just and I mean
compared this compared to like Cannibal
Holocaust there's like not even any
comparison so later speculation has it
that when the British Board of Film
censors were looking for you know movies
to prosecute they actually got this
movie confused with another movie that's
actually better known by the title Last
House on dead-end street but under some
markets was released as the fun house to
words so and that film was like way
worse and like way gory and [ __ ] so I
feel like that's probably the one they
were aiming for and they just got it kid
got a mixed up because this one's called
the funhouse that was called the
funhouse yeah I also wanted to and Rob
who sent us this movie also sent me a
little video about this today that
apparently after the movie came out
there was a novelization of it and it
was written by Dean Koontz okay although
he was at first he wrote under a
pseudonym though I guess later he put
his actual name on it and tobe Hooper
was saying he's like you know I got some
copies of the book like at the time but
I didn't read them because I thought you
know it's just like a piece of
merchandising and it's probably not very
good Dooku wrote it but yeah but he's
like a couple years ago I actually sat
down to read he's like that book is
actually pretty good
I didn't it like goes into like a lot of
the backstory the carnival on the
backstory the characters and [ __ ] like
that I haven't read it but I've heard
it's like actually pretty decent I have
to say I'm not a huge Dean Koontz fan
some of his [ __ ] is good but I'm gonna
have to like seek this out and read it
because I'm kind of interested to see
what he did with the story like I said I
love [ __ ] that said in carnivals yeah
was his mama cow that oh yeah oh I
wonder what says in the book yeah call
me Dean Koontz is it so I guess he is
yes tell me was that
what's that guy [ __ ] account well
his dad did said that you see what he
was kind of like a demon did ya well
yeah he did kind of sense like a demon
or something there was no it was
he's scrawny but he makes up for it I
guess in ferocity and the fact that he
doesn't really appear quite human yeah
well he definitely wouldn't win them out
when the mask comes on he actually to me
not even when I was a little kid he look
like an albino vampire bat he did yeah
it looked like to me yeah he looks like
animalistic yeah I mean he's clearly
supposed to be like a deformed human but
he hangs like he had fangs like a
vampire bat big wide spaced eyes and his
eyes were pink and they they just didn't
because they were so far apart they they
didn't look like the human eyes like
animal eyes yeah and like I said this I
think they only rip the little girls
apart and stuff like that
yeah and then his dad said he ripped him
apart I don't remember if he said that
or not yeah but one thing they did in
this which you know the same kind of
thing they did in Frankenstein and King
Kong everything like that was they made
the villain the monster he was kind of
sympathetic to because he couldn't help
looking like that and he wasn't like
smart enough to really know what he was
doing and like the way that his dad
treated him is like oh I should have
strangled you at birth yes dad Vito he
was like super abusive and stuff so you
almost kind of felt bad for him to back
off of it though but you know his dad
was a dick yeah like his dad later be
like oh I'm sorry I didn't mean that
blah blah but that's like something that
he's also kind of like it yeah I think
he was also kind of manipulating him to
get him to go to to finish to me exactly
exactly that's exactly what he was doing
yeah cuz he was oh I'm sorry just like
let's just do what I told you to do and
everything'll be okay and like you know
I won't be mad at you and stuff like
that so you did kind of feel sorry
although he did tell he did tell the
victims before you killed him that one
scene he says that he would he's not
much to look at but he will be a great
comfort to me in my old age yeah so I
don't know was the employment he could
send him out to go kill people or was
just gonna take care of him I don't know
yeah because I'm like that I don't think
I don't think that Gunther was gonna be
taking care of anything yeah I don't
think it'd be too much
much for help I mean you know know what
I don't think so either
I mean I guess he could maybe I guess
you know I guess you could do stuff
around this what we're thinking too much
and put into reading too much into
movies really this is a b-movie welcome
and that's what we do well done b-movie
yeah if you like Toby Cooper's other
movies and I don't see any reason why
you wouldn't like this one like I said
it's it's a pretty good um you know
slash Ursula you know slasher sort of
monster movie from the early 80s um kind
of better than a lot of the ones that
came out at the time yeah it's better
than fog I put it at the same level and
I'd like start off with like the fog
right yeah but better yeah what else can
you think is exact but I'll never closer
to it you think oh you're putting me on
this body I'm putting you on the spot
maybe mm I don't really know actually
what's that what would be about that
same level I know it's a one movie that
I really liked that I saw at the time I
think it came out the same year as this
was my Bloody Valentine although I think
this was better than my Bloody Valentine
just because it looks more stylish yeah
My Bloody Valentine I feel like I
haven't seen it in a while but I
remember it being more workman like
around same Tamils of terror train and
I'd say this is Ben Oh
terror train was real good too but like
terror train was shot like that was like
pretty classy looking I remember it was
okay you know what this story actually
is better than Friday the 13th part one
well obviously yeah it's a lot more
atmospheric oh my god there's out it
didn't have the same you know it wasn't
the same slasher kill scenes and yes
effects this movie doesn't actually need
that no like I said this pretty tame
like as far as violence and gore and
stuff goes okay you know what you know
what I'm gonna put this at the same
level I'm gonna put it that pretty much
the same level as The Hills Have Eyes
yeah okay I would say about like that I
was good at was probably gonna say that
the thing that probably elevates this
one is the whole carnival setting
because it almost becomes its own
character you know what I mean because
and you can tell that it's a real
functioning carnival like some of the
shots he gets of it I forgot to mention
that he did two really amazing crane
shots in this yeah yes maybe are some of
the first ones ever done he said
I'd like it a hundred and fifteen dust
really I mentioned it yeah it is that a
crane or something that was hotter than
50 fan he said it was in three sections
yeah you didn't you would I would didn't
expect that because that just not
removing at that time period they know
they do it much Mel then early eighties
b-movie slasher type horror movie a
crane shots you'd expect shots like like
now it's easy cuz you can do [ __ ] with
drones and yeah like that but I was like
I know I was surprised to what I saw
that shot I'm like holy crap I was
waiting for it to cut it goes now they
can't keep going yeah that's gonna cut
Annika no I went on a good yeah he said
it was a [ __ ] that crane it wasn't made
for that he said we just had it and we
had the idea to put the camera on it was
an I had to climb up on it it was a
hundred fifty was a nice sanction that
lifted and full pullback and pans the
top and I was you know I was like man
they went through the whole range of
motion yeah there were two shots like
that in the movie and they were really
nicely done so like I said the whole
setting of this really really elevates
it I think into something better than a
lot of the slashers of the period just
because the carnival setting is like so
rich and it's colorful and there's like
so much you can do with it and it's also
kind of like has that whole creepy seedy
underbelly of America it's a vibe that's
like so effective and what was funny is
that at the time it got no recognition
it just kind of went unnoticed because
of the genre I mean yeah horror was just
like bottom of the barrel
no matter yeah fairly it got mixed to
positive reviews if I'm the Exorcist or
the omen that you can get so loved it
Getty
yeah really like you saw for what it was
then yeah he recognized greatness yeah
because of the average person you know
back in those days we we know that did
we grew up back then if it wasn't the
Exorcist or the omen then it was a cheap
a low-budget movie they didn't give a
[ __ ] yeah people didn't really
appreciate any bridges I think the way
they appreciate them now I'm like I'm
not saying that there weren't a lot of
them weren't cheap knockoffs and they
sucked because they did but I don't know
a lot of movies in every genre cheap
knockoffs we got to do evil speak we did
that already
you did evil speak okay we've done so
many of my for you sure we did evil
speak I remember I was going for that a
while back yeah there's a bunch we have
to do like I said we bought some and
it's like I just pushed this one up
because Rob said it too
it was kind of a surprise and I was like
well I was like we'll do this on the
next show then and I'm just really sorry
that my voice sounds so crappy and I've
like had to stop and go off and all this
other kind of crap so hopefully it's not
too annoying for you yeah we might have
to edit some coughing out yeah we'll see
I might not I might get too lazy much
then shut it down I mean your voice is
given out it yeah it is alright so that
will do it for our retrospective on tobe
Hooper's 1981 film the fun house hope
you guys enjoyed it and thanks again Rob
for sending us a copy of it we really
appreciate it
remember if you liked the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and there is a little button in the
sidebar to a PayPal account we will see
you next time bye